un chevalier des temps modernes pourquoi
pas happy fondateur de la compagnie
d'improvisation des kits théâtre attrape
mène depuis plus de vingt ans de
nombreuses batailles son fer de lance
rendre légitime l'improvisation comme
discipline à part entière du théâtre
public
si cette reconnaissance institutionnelle
se fait encore attendre
pape sy a pourtant été promu il ya
quelques semaines
chevalier de l'ordre des arts et des
lettres effectivement que la ministre de
la culture fasse le choix de de
reconnaître mon travail en disant vous
avez fait un tel travail que je le
reconnais et à tel point je vous nomme
chevalier des arts et lettres n'a pas
tant que ça en plus il ya un ministre il
dit qui me tend la main en disant moi je
vous reconnais véritable dénicheur de
talents pape sy a participé à
l'émergence de la génération stand up
de nombreux artistes comme km de blues
sophia aram warnotte sa mère sont entrés
dans la patinoire de déclic théâtre
avant d'être reconnu par le grand public
sommes engagés armée de conviction pape
sy estime qu'aujourd'hui une nouvelle
culture est en marche
encore une fois on fait bouger des
lignes la culture et que peut-être que
c'est tour d'ivoire sont en train de se
se fissurer ayez une nouvelle culture à
faire je pense que l'insurrection
culturel est en marche
merci nana ministre s'y donner à
l'improvisation ses lettres de noblesse
n'est pas chose aisée un chevalier dans
ses rangs en facilitera peut-être l'axé
m